on sait mes chers collègues nous ont
tendance ce matin en audition commune
monsieur Édouard Fritz le président de
la Polynésie française et Gaston
tanksong président de l'assemblée de la
Polynésie française dans le cadre de
notre étude sur l'évolution
institutionnelle des Outre-mer nous
remercions très vivement Messieurs les
Présidents de vous être rendus
disponible pour répondre à nos questions
malgré un emploi du temps que nous avons
chargé et leur tardif pour vous et
matinal pour nous je salue également
Lana qui participe depuis son territoire
à cette audition et était là qui et de
ce côté-ci de la de du monde vous êtes
entouré de Madame Marie-Laure Denis
directrice de cabinet du président de la
Polynésie française et de monsieur
Étienne Howard conseiller juridique
auprès du président de la Polynésie
française et Philippe Machenaud
secrétaire général de gouvernement je
vous indique que nous sommes déjà à
mi-chemin de notre consultations il
s'agit précisément de notre sixième
audition après Saint-Barthélémy la
Réunion Wallis-et-Futuna Saint-Martin et
Saint-Pierre Miquelon lorsqu'il est
question de l'autonomie est souvent
évoqué le modèle polynésien
sur la base du questionnaire qui vous a
été adressé vous nous direz messieurs
qui est le bilan voudrait c'est de la
pratique de vos institutions depuis la
loi organique 2004 et les perspectives
que font naître une éventuelle révision
constitutionnelle en 2023 je vais vous
céder la parole monsieur le Président
Édouard pour un exposé liminaire puis ce
sera le tour de du président Gaston
Thonon song pour nous éclairer sur la
manière dont votre collectivité fait
vivre au statut et sur les aménagements
que vous souhaiteriez éventuellement
avec misting Jack en quoi rapporteur en
nous interrogerons ensuite ainsi que nos
collègues qui participent en présentiel
je vous précise simplement avant de
commencer messieurs et chers Lana ou que
nous y disposons d'environs 1h15 une
heure 20 puisque derrière nous
organisons une table ronde à la
délégation sur la gestion des déchets en
outre-mer sur le volet fiscalité que
bien évidemment nous sommes preneurs de
vos contributions écrites
ultérieurement à cette audition qui
viendrait enrichir les échanges que nous
aurions ce matin voilà donc je préférais
vous le dire on soit tous à l'aise avec
le calendrier et Monsieur Fritsch vous
avez la parole
mais c'est bien
pour cette rencontre effectivement en
nous ne sommes pas si tard que ça nous
sommes le 20h le
même que l'histoire par contre je sais
que c'est plutôt pour pour la métropole
en tous les cas merci pour cet entretien
je vous adresse à toutes et à tous nos
salutations effectivement je suis
accompagné par le président de
l'Assemblée de Polynésie française et
notre sénatrice de Polynésie madame la
nuit
[Musique]
à l'exécutif et voire même à la
législatif ici en Polynésie à
l'Assemblée de Polynésie française
néanmoins il y a effectivement quelques
réserves effectivement le
régime de libre gouvernement ainsi que
la répartition des compétences qui sont
prévues par le statut de 2004
aujourd'hui permet aux autorités locales
de gérer les affaires du pays avec des
règles conçus et adopté localement je
pense que c'est effectivement
le principe de base le plus important et
c'est ce qui a été réclamé par le monde
politique ici en premier des Françaises
et ceux pratiquement des années 60
globalement donc cette répartition des
compétences issues de la loi organique
de 2004 est satisfaisante
sous quelques réserves
ce qu'on appelle par exemple que le
transfert des compétences entre l'État
et le pays étaient insuffisamment
accompagnés et non évaluer à la juste de
mesures la Polynésie française
effectivement participe
à exercer ses compétences mais je dois
vous dire que pour quelques-unes d'entre
elles nous avons quelques difficultés
que je veux dire d'autre part c'est que
en matière
d'organisation des
institutions du fonctionnement des
institutions ici le domaine de la loi
organique nous l'avons déjà dit lors de
la modification statutaire de 2019 que
la loi organique devrait être limité aux
éléments essentiels vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le statut de la Polynésie
française
dans l'organisation
et avec précision de l'exécutif avec
force du pays avec le nombre de
ministres fixés par la loi et un budget
de fonctionnement du gouvernement qui
est lui-même limité par la loi
[Musique]
du statut je pense souvent aux
difficultés que nous avons pour
l'application des des articles
concernant
les communes de Polynésie française
vous savez que aujourd'hui les communes
jouent un rôle très important chez nous
et
nous essayons effectivement de les
accompagner dans leur développement et
les communes malheureusement n'ayant pas
la compétence générale sauf limitées en
matière de compétences alors que
certains de ces maires de Polynésie
française souhaiteraient pouvoir exercer
certaines délégations certaines
compétences du pays je pense par exemple
à la compétence
du social de la Jeunesse et des Sports
l'avis associative des choses qui sont
les sujets qui sont qui sont très
préoccupants pour pour s'aimer dans le
cas de la gestion de leur commune et
aujourd'hui donc nous essayons de télé
comment dire de trouver des solutions
dans le cadre de l'application des
articles du statut qui prévoit
effectivement nos 43-2 le 48 et le 55
qui prévoit que le pays puisse
effectivement partager cette compétences
avec avec les communes mais le pays est
en cours de mise en œuvre de ces de ces
articles mais il faut reconnaître que
l'exercice est complexe compte tenu de
ces articles qui sont spécifiques à la
Polynésie française et donc une
publicité de faire du sur-mesure pour
pouvoir laisser aux communes cette
possibilité
d'exercer de partager certaines
compétences avec nous cette
voilà c'est aujourd'hui les
nous déplorons c'est une remarque que je
voudrais vous faire aussi à nous
déploignons la répartition des la
répartition des compétences
soient souvent aujourd'hui prise comme
justificatif pour ne pas associer la
Polynésie française à certaines
politiques nationales je pense par
exemple à la gestion des fonds très au
début
certaines politiques que la santé on est
systématiquement écarté des politiques
nationales du fait que nous soyons nous
voyez-vous de soyez de Soyons compétents
dans ces matières mais bon aujourd'hui
le
statut de la Polynésie française la
statue que nous avons pratiqué depuis
maintenant
1984 il a besoin effectivement
vraisemblablement d'évaluer pour
certaines compétences je viens nous
venons tous de sortir de la crise de
covid nous a vendu partager avec l'État
à certaines compétences je veux parler
de la santé pour la compétence de
polynésienne et pour l'État la liberté
de circulation
la liberté de
[Musique]
oui de circuler et là il faut dire que
on a l'impression effectivement que
pendant cette crise du covid c'est la
pression de la population polynésienne
que je que je traduis ici en a
l'impression que
l'État effectivement exercer son poids
sur la liberté de circuler mais
néanmoins nous sommes retrouvés nous
pays avec notre compétence de la santé
complètement absent de ces décisions et
là aussi bon je pense qu'il faudra que
l'on réfléchisse à aménagé cette
compétence de l'Etat je crois que c'est
un vrai problème technique bien sûr mais
je vois qu'il faut que l'on trouve un
milieu a juste milieu de façon à ce que
dans ces moments de crise
la sanitaire
que le pays puisse lui prendre
de la main sur sur l'organisation locale
en matière de crise prochaine
je voudrais vous dire aussi que mon
certain difficultés sont rencontrées si
on Polynésie française en matière de
protection à l'accès offensiers en
matière de protection de longs noirs
vous savez que depuis bien certain temps
la Polynésie française à l'instar de ce
qui se fait en Nouvelle-Calédonie par le
beaucoup de citoyenneté la Calédonie
c'était plus une citoyenneté pour des
raisons électorales mais ici en
Polynésie française nous en avons
beaucoup discuté lors des dernières
élections législatives ou ce sujet
effectivement est devenu et il nous
faudra je ne veux pas je ne suis pas
bloqué sur la citoyenneté et il nous
faudra trouver des aménagements des
articles du statut qui prévoit un des
compétences du pays dans cette matière
nous avons été retoqué en Conseil d'État
il y a quelques temps de cela
mais aujourd'hui commençons à avancer un
petit peu mais je pense que les
résultats sont attendus et rapidement si
possible je pense à aussi à des
compétences du pays en matière de
relation à l'international
vous savez que le pays
la Polynésie française aujourd'hui fait
partie de certaines associations
internationales nous sommes au Forum des
îles du Pacifique
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué nous
avons avec par exemple nous avons avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande décider de
construire un câble transpacifique de
propriété vers les îles Samoa
[Musique]
je n'ai pas vu conclure rapidement
l'accord avec la Nouvelle-Zélande même
si ce ne fut plus un canapé commercial
la page effectivement il a fallu que je
demande auprès de pouvoir réaliser une
telle opération je pense que dans nous
ne demandons pas à l'extension des
compétences en matière de relation
internationale sur le plan diplomatique
et dans le cadre d'un code qui a été
mené déjà et conclu avec l'État français
mais je pense que dans le cadre de du
rayonnement de la Polynésie française au
nom de l'État même au nom de la France
dans cette zone du Pacifique devait on
devrait lui donner une liberté d'action
pour conclure certains accords avec nous
nos amis du Pacifique voilà si vous
voulez grosso modo je pense qu'on a on a
déjà parlé lors de la dernière rencontre
certaines
que je vois sur l'évolution statutaire
de la Polynésie française sur le reste
je
vous dis toute notre satisfaction
aujourd'hui de l'exercice de l'autonomie
ici en polynastie française les
compétences de la pollinisation
française que nous assumons et des
moyens bien sûr financiers dont nous
avons l'autonomie et qui nous permettent
d'exercer ses compétences mais au moins
reste comme je vous l'ai dit que ça soit
dans le cadre de la solidarité nationale
s'asseoir dans le cadre de politique
nationale
la possibilité pour la Polynésie de ne
pas être exclus systématiquement parce
que elle a la compétence dans ses
matières
voilà ce que je peux vous dire dans un
premier temps
[Musique]
une super son temps peut-être
si vous le souhaitez président
et l'assemblée Polynésie française je
vais peut-être
rajouter quelque chose sur
l'accessibilité à l'intelligibilité de
l'ITECH parce que ça fait l'objet
d'ailleurs les discussions à Paris lors
de la modification de l'avoir organique
au mois de juillet 2019 et a eu une
mission qui a été commandée mais on
attend toujours les résultats de l'impôt
cette mission parce que c'est très
compliqué de
d'avoir accès au bon texte applicable à
la police française donc je suis
français
je reviens un petit peu sur les
collectivités que sont les communes
totalement la place dans l'organisation
de nos institutions ici en Polynésie
française et
on parlait des transferts des
compétences dans le domaine social
économique même du pays vers les
communes moi je tendance plutôt à parler
des compétences qui sont déjà transférés
au problème que son lot l'assainissement
et les déchets c'est des compétences qui
sont très lourdes
techniquement et financièrement et à
l'époque de ces transferts
il a été mis en place une commission
d'évaluation
pas la chambre territorique
justement pour
pour montrer à l'état et aux communes
l'immensité de
représentent ces transferts compétences
assez collectivités qui étaient
complètement dépourvues des moyens et
pire que ça la loi fixée date limite
pour que les communes puissent offrir de
l'eau potable à la population traiter
tous les organisés et mettre en place
des dispositifs des traitement des
déchets on a repoussé deux fois la date
parce que on était dans l'incapacités de
respecter ces dates je pense que l'eau
c'est 2024 c'est l'assainissement c'est
plus tard et même ces attelages je suis
convaincu que toutes les Polynésie
pourront pas respecter ces dates pour la
simple raison on n'a aucun dispositif
très clair permettant d'accompagner les
communes
juridiquement et financièrement à
exercer ses compétences voilà moi je
pense que français c'est des nouvelles
compétences au mieux déjà régler les
anciennes les confidences de base
j'allais dire
pour les communes de français
donc c'est quelque chose je voulais
rajouter aux propos du président et bien
sûr
depuis 2007 ce statut fonctionne bien
surtout depuis que la nouvelle loi
électorale a été mise en place ça nous a
évité cette période pénible
d'instabilité politique qui a démarré de
2004 jusqu'à 2012 avec c'est presque
deux mandats d'instabilité politique on
n'est pas près de revivre cette période
là donc au moins la modification de la
loi de scrutin élector a permis à la
politique française
[Musique]
je pense à un statut qui qui fonctionne
et je dirais tout simplement que
peut-être c'est un dispositif de la loi
organique a été conçu à l'époque de
cette stabilité je me souviens on a
limité les moyens
de fonctionnement d'un gouvernement par
des mesures que je considère
non pas du tout adapté à l'autonomie de
la police française cette compétence
devait revenir à l'Assemblée et non pas
à la loi organique je pense il y a
peut-être cette rectification
retrouve bien son autonomie que
[Musique]
je me souviens dans les années 2012 où
sont où on a retiré cette ces moyens
d'autonomie à la police française voilà
ce que je voulais dire
dans le domaine du bilan de l'autonomie
[Musique]
merci Messieurs les Présidents juste
rebondir peut-être sur l'aspect des
communes et le constat que vous venez de
faire est-ce que ça a suscité de la part
des communes un transfert en sens
inverse d'une compétence qu'il n'aurait
pas pu ou su exercer par exemple parce
que c'est une question qu'on peut
d'ailleurs poser également entre le pays
et l'État est-ce qu'il y a des
compétences que vous souhaiteriez voir
revenir à l'état par exemple ou est-ce
que sur le sujet de la des strates
communales est-ce que vous avez constaté
le même phénomène c'est à dire que une
commune qui n'a pas les moyens ou pas
l'accompagnement est-ce qu'il y a eu des
sollicitations pour ce mouvement inverse
arrive de partout tous les tous les
maires de Polynésie française
aujourd'hui on devrait difficultés pour
ne serait-ce que livrer de l'eau potable
dans les communes
sachez que par exemple dans les atomes
l'eau potable vu par les populations et
d'issue et des pluies récoltés par des
toitures collectées dans des systèmes et
des populations boivent cette eau parce
qu'il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de source
d'eau potable chez eux
donc aujourd'hui l'ensemble des communes
de la Polynésie française ne vivent pas
encore et ne satisfait pas aux
obligations du CGCT cette matière mais
pire mais pire c'est effectivement le
problème de l'assainissement des eaux
usées
là aussi il y a bon je vous enverrai les
précisions plus tard mais il y a un
problème de compétences entre le pays et
les communes sur la reconnaissance des
systèmes de traitement d'eau usées
individuels les stompes et là bon nous
sommes en train de encore nous battre
enfin les juristes bien sûr mais nous
sommes en train de battre pour arriver à
une solution qui et qui soit clair pour
tout le monde mais le pire de cette
affaire c'est quand même le traitement
des eaux collectifs
le système d'assainissement collectif
ici en Polynésie française coûte
excessivement cher et c'est vrai que
lors du transfert de la compétence je
parle en tant que mère aussi mais le
transfert des compétences
aux communes n'a pas été accompagné du
tout de moyens qu'il soit d'ingénierie
des moyens techniques ou des moyens
financiers pour pouvoir satisfaire la
bonne ex de le bon exercice de ses
compétences et aujourd'hui les mers sont
dépass
aujourd'hui certaines communes ont la
volonté de le faire mais dès que vous le
gardez le résultat des études vous êtes
où j'étais vous jeter les banques donc
voilà alors il y a un autre sujet qui va
arriver vraisemblablement très bientôt
c'est celui du traitement des ordures
ménagères dans nos collectivités c'est
un secteur qui va qui est aussi très
budgétivore mais qui est surtout
qui va surtout poser de gros problèmes à
l'environnement ici en Polynésie
française
[Musique]
les les déchets déchets ménagés en
Polynésie française
pose un véritable problème aux communes
les communes le recouvrent pratiquement
et en moyenne que le tiède et le devant
sur l'ensemble des du budget dédiés à un
traitement à la collecte et au
traitement des ordures ménagères c'est
exorbitant compris et nous ne pouvons
pas augmenter les taxes parce que dès le
devant parce que les contribuables ne
paieront pas nous avons aussi des
communes rurales ou les revenus sont pas
donc voilà en fait ce dont on a besoin
c'est effectivement de prévoir quelque
part dans le statut dans la loi que les
communes si le législateur décidait de
leur laisser ses compétences que les
communes soient accompagnées
financièrement et techniquement pour
qu'il soit en règle avec le CGC
on matière d'accompagnement messieurs
comment est-ce que vous jugez
l'accompagnement de l'État sur sur
l'aspect des compétences de votre
territoire est-ce que les transferts
mais vous avez commencé à le dire tout à
l'heure n'ont pas forcément été toujours
bien évalués tel que si j'ai bien
compris ou est-ce qu'il y a un
accompagnement supplémentaire serait
nécessaire et par exemple sur l'aspect
des communes est-ce que c'est
typiquement le le type de réflexion que
vous êtes fait
oui effectivement bon moi je pense que
il est pas trop tard de faire
une bonne mission d'évaluation
peut-être demander à la Chambre
territoriale des Condes à qui on avait
commandé ce travail
de remettre à jour
ce travail d'évaluation et de soumettre
le rapport au pays à l'état et
pourquoi pas en commun de manière à ce
que chaque partie mesure bien le chemin
qui reste à faire parce que pour
beaucoup
ils sont à peine à la moitié du chemin à
parcourir et l'objectif c'est de
d'assurer une santé publique à tous nos
citoyens pour que chacun puisse accéder
à l'eau potable de qualité déjà sur ce
plan là et bien sûr
l'assainissement collectif des eaux
usées le traitement des déchets
viendront bien naturellement dans dans
la suite de ces de ces projets et là ça
demande quand même des moyens importants
et peut-être c'est le moment aussi de
dire que une commune de la Polynésie
française combien même la Polynésie a un
statut particulier qui est l'autonomie
une commune
la commune les communes de politique
français sont toutes régies par le Code
Général des Collectivités Territoriales
donc c'est la base commune de toutes les
communes de la République en dehors de
la Nouvelle-Calédonie et nous pensons
nous disons que étant régi par le droit
commun des collectivités territoriales
que sont les communes il est normal que
les communes de la Polynésie française
doit être considéré de la sorte et
qu'elle puisse accéder à des fonds
importants je trouve qu'on peut qu'on
peut avoir en France ou en Europe moi je
pense qu'il faut pas écarter les moyens
au niveau des fonds européens voilà je
pense que c'est une façon d'aider les
communes justement après aboutir exercé
pleinement ces compétences
je vais compléter monsieur le Président
salut à tous mes chers collègues
pour avoir tenté essayer de faire passer
c'est à dire la participation de l'État
au niveau des communes je parle du FIP
en 2019 quand il y a eu la révision
statutaire je parle des collectivités de
l'État je parle pas des dotations la
compagnement de l'État envers la
collectivité Polynésie je parle bien des
collectivités locales qui sont sur le
régime par l'État elle-même nous avons
et je ne vais pas en démondre à savoir
que au moins l'État au niveau du film le
fond intercommunal de péréquation vient
au moins s'aligner ne serait-ce même
niveau que la collectivité les communes
quand même sont des collectivités de
l'État le pays donne quoi
un ordre d'échelle je crois on est entre
du 60 et du 30% ne serait-ce que pour le
fait c'était la petite précision que je
voulais apporter monsieur le président
le si je peux me permettre la pour pour
ma culture personnelle est-ce que ça
veut dire que on aurait pu opposer par
exemple le statut d'autonomie du
territoire pour dire finalement vous
n'avez qu'à vous débrouiller sur le site
voilà je vais je suis très très direct
mais est-ce que c'est le type d'argument
qu'on a qu'on a opposé par exemple
oui parce que voilà président Édouard
vient de vous dire vous n'avez les
communes n'ont pas la cause de
compétences générales ils vont venir ils
nous ont déjà noyé le poisson en disant
écoutez ok votre fille la DGF pendant
tant d'années sur les communes
métropolitaines ont vu leur dotation PC
alors que le nôtre sa femme a bougé mais
c'était un combat mené par mon
prédécesseur de sénateur à savoir que la
DGF des communes Polynésie sont indexées
sur la DGA ok mais c'est un combat mené
par département
voilà c'est le genre de d'arguments
qu'on nous sort vous avez voulu
autonomie vous n'avez pas la compétence
générale voilà tu as dit les mots mais
voilà je vais rester poli ce soir
moi aussi mais ça m'a pas empêché d'être
direct
il faut essayer de bien saisir et je me
doutais bien que c'était le type
d'argument enfin c'est le même type
d'arguments qu'on nous oppose aussi sur
internet sur certains de nos territoires
qui relèvent de l'article 74 on sort un
champ de compétences c'est vous l'avez
souhaité entre guillemets j'ai presque
envie de vous dire débrouillez-vous et
débrouillez-vous maintenant avec
l'exercice de la compétence si on va sur
le côté si on reste sur le côté état
avant d'aller sur le volet plus
constitutionnel qui avait d'ailleurs été
abordé déjà avec Michel Magra à l'époque
en 2020 est-ce que la déconcentration
des services de l'État permet justement
à l'état d'adapter ses politiques sur le
territoire vous savez qu'il y a une
capacité pour le commissaire par exemple
à déroger sur la base du décret du 8
avril 2020 un certain nombre de de
règles justement pour les adapter à la
Polynésie française est-ce que ça a été
mis en oeuvre ou ou pas du tout où
est-ce qu'il y en a besoin peut-être
si vous voulez en résumait non
ça n'a pas ça n'a pas vraiment été mise
en oeuvre ici en Polynésie française
c'est effectivement cette
déconcentration
aurait permis
à l'état de d'appliquer plus d'une façon
beaucoup plus appropriée beaucoup plus
d'adaptation aux spécificités du pays
dans ces domaines de compétences on est
toujours donc pour l'État mais mieux
adapté au contexte local franchement ici
en Polynésie française j'ai peu
d'exemples de cette application donc des
concentration ici
en Polynésie en tous les cas mais ceci
dit c'est faut savoir même au-delà
puisque
nous-mêmes le gouvernement de française
dès le départ n'avait pas été consulté
du tout sur l'extension à la Polynésie
française donc c'est des choses bon
et je crois même si je ne m'abuse que le
haut-commissaire lui-même n'a pas été
consulté à ce jour sur son application
ici en Polynésie française donc voilà
c'est c'est une compétence de l'État je
ne veux pas non plus juger l'action de
l'État dans ces dans l'application de
ses compétences ici en Polynésie
française c'est une observation que je
fais mais c'est ça je voulais je voulais
je voulais répondre assez précisément à
une question que vous avez posé
précédemment d'abord donc
est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'État nous accompagne suffisamment dans
l'exercice de nos compétences
la Polynésie une histoire
un petit peu un petit peu différente des
autres collectivités car comme vous le
savez
nous avons l'autonomie interne à
l'autonomie de gestion de leur pays
l'autonomie
polynésienne depuis les années 84 et ce
jusque vers la fin des années du 20e
siècle jusqu'en 2000 nous étions dans
l'air du CEP du centre d'expérimentation
du Pacifique effectivement pendant toute
cette époque
on ne sait pas réellement rendu compte
des certaines difficultés que nous
avions à appliquer et à exercer notre
autonomie parce que vous comprenez bien
que pendant cette époque-là les choses
étaient beaucoup plus facile à régler la
Polynésie était effectivement au service
de l'État et l'État a été franchement je
dois le dire l'État était assez généreux
vis-à-vis de la Polynésie française
c'est les choses ont effectivement
changé à partir du début du 21e avec le
à partir de l'an 2000 ou cette
contribution permanente de l'État avec
la présence de des armées avec la
présence de l'administration militaire
ici en Polynésie française et tout
l'argent qui va avec pour être court
c'est arrêter et là la Polynésie
française effectivement s'est rendu
compte que voilà l'autonomie ça a un
coût et il faut il faut il faut le gérer
alors fort heureusement il faut le dire
l'état qui s'est rendu compte aussi que
non seulement il y a eu ce mouvement de
population des îles vers le centre Haïti
parce que les les plus lourds du centre
d'alimentation était d'ici et pour aller
sur des sites il fallait passer par la
police de
donc on s'est rendu compte effectivement
que il y avait un hyper développement de
l'île de Tahiti comme de l'atoll de Hao
qui était de la base arrière et que le
reste de la Polynésie française en fin
de compte
n'existait presque pas non l'État est
effectivement et c'est quoi c'était le
président Jacques Chirac qui a
effectivement mis en place des fonds
d'accompagnement de la Polynésie
française c'était fondé le conversion au
départ et puis c'est devenu entre
guillemets la dette de l'État là en
Polynésie française où elle intervenait
je dois le connaître encore aujourd'hui
d'éteindre intervient massivement tu le
rééquilibrage des infrastructures ici en
Polynésie française donc c'est beaucoup
plus effectivement des interventions en
matière d'investissement dans notre pays
et cela bien sûr nous aide énormément le
développement contraire serait sur les
cacher la vérité
mais mais d'autres difficultés sont
apparues et vous le savez sur le plan
sanitaire par exemple
et sur le plan conséquemment sur le plan
des fonds sociaux la sécurité sociale en
Polynésie française c'est la Caisse de
compensation à la CPS ici
par effet effectivement à lui aussi
beaucoup souffert le système qui a été
mis en place en 1994 ici en Polynésie
française nous avons une espèce de
couverture générale de la population que
vous cotisiez ou pas nous était couverts
vous avez des allocations vous avez des
retraites vous avez vous êtes soigné à
l'hôpital ici à répéter a fait que le
système c'est petit à petit
effectivement financièrement allouri
alors la Polynésie se déroule nous avons
nous avons un système fiscal qui est le
nôtre nous nous essayons de les prendre
effectivement au besoin
du pays mais il faut bien qu'il y a des
moments où nous sommes dans d'énormes
d'énormes difficultés parce que
effectivement nous subissons les crises
économique comme tout le monde je pense
à la crise de 2008 2010 je pense à la
crise de la covid bon là effectivement
c'est des situations complètement
exceptionnelles mais il faut aussi le
connaître que aujourd'hui sur le plan
sanitaire nous gênons continuons à gérer
les conséquences des essais nucléaires
je ne vais pas je ne vais pas plaider
pour pour les Antilles nucléaires mais
c'est vrai que le système de santé en
Polynésie française est en train de
coûter de plus en recherche à la
Polynésie parce que on a de nombreux cas
de cancer conséquemment aux essais
nucléaires et tout cela aujourd'hui
vient mettre en difficulté nos fonds
sociaux c'est la raison pour laquelle et
effectivement nous avons formulé cette
année encore une un appel au secours à
l'état
la solidarité nationale pour qu'elle
vienne nous aider parce que
effectivement après la crise du covid
les choses en pays encore plus de
difficultés et sont devenus de plus en
plus les fonds sont devenus de plus en
plus exemples et nous avons fait
d'ailleurs à cette occasion nous avons
fait un prêt à garanti à l'état pour
pour venir
de ces concours
oui oui il y a il y a effectivement un
système social qui est très généreux
chez nous mais qui va qui coûte
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'argent néanmoins
en Polynésie française vous le savez
bien nous n'avons pas de caisse de
chômage et ici en Polynésie si vous ne
travaillez pas vous ne gagnez pas avant
il faut se mettre au travail nous avons
un système d'aide
d'un accompagnement de nos chemins ici
au travers des employés qui permettent à
chacun de se de pouvoir gagner un petit
peu d'argent mais bon le la situation
est quand même assez fragile et comme
vous le savez pendant la crise du covid
par exemple parce que
nous étions retournons nous n'avons pas
pu bénéficier d'allocations chômage
spécialement servi à ceux qui qui
souffraient de
la covid et pour les entreprises nous
avons du nous nous-mêmes à faire face à
ce type de solidarité et là à moins on
s'est débrouillé tout seul c'est aussi
ça l'autonomie bien sûr j'ai envie de
vous dire
bien sûr qu'on a envie que la l'état
nous accompagne toujours plus parce que
ça nous éviterait d'alourdir les impôts
ici en Polynésie française bien que le
niveau soit quand même qu'on a fait lui
à la celui de la France mais c'est
effectivement un exercice qui est très
intéressant parce que l'autonomie nous
donne le pouvoir de décision à nous
donne des compétences dans l'exercice de
l'exécutif et législatif mais à côté de
cela effectivement il faut prendre des
responsabilités et puis savoir souff
pour résumer Président j'ai presque
envie de dire que l'autonomie c'est la
responsabilisation des acteurs de nos
territoires et je pense que là vous
venez de le démontrer et ça me permet de
rebondir sur sur un autre sujet avant de
laisser la parole à Micheline sur la
partie plus constitutionnelle le
président de la République a engagé avec
un certain nombre de collectivités à
l'occasion d'un repas à l'Elysée le 7
septembre dernier un processus de de
concertation sur un certain nombre de
secteurs qui peuvent balayer
l'environnement l'économie le social
avant d'aboutir peut-être pour certains
de ces territoires à des évolutions
institutionnelles ou pas est-ce que la
polynie serait également demandéeuse
d'un processus de concertation pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez sur les
constats que vous avez opéré notamment
par exemple en matière de crise
sanitaire qui permettrait peut-être de
faire bouger les lignes et d'adapter les
choses pour prévenir d'autres crises qui
pourraient survenir autre que sanitaire
par exemple
je suis convaincu du fait que on est on
est plus intelligent à plusieurs et que
on tombe de les expériences des uns et
les autres ne peut être que positif y
compris pour ceux qui en ont plus que
les autres oui bien sûr que je suis pas
le temps d'ailleurs je n'avais pas
ajouté n'avait pas prévu de venir à ce
débat au Sénat qui est prévu lors de
du Congrès des Maires
prochaines mais en fin de compte j'ai
décidé de venir de participer à ce débat
qui se tiendra dans vos murs
au Sénat parce que je vois que
la solidarité je parle de la solidarité
des ultramarins des
océaniques
comment que effectivement avant de se
lancer dans de telles expériences que
nous puissions nous aussi apporter à
notre contribution à la réflexion voir
même bon les mettre en garde profiter de
notre expérience en fin de compte pour
contribuer à ce que ces pays parce que
ces pays parce que c'était toi
département d'outre-mer qui aspire à
autre chose puisse trouver le bon chemin
Stéphane pardon mais
sur la question je revendique sur la
déconcentration
cela déconcentration en fait bien 20
mots on aime bien appeler chez nous dans
nos lisons le truc
concentration la différenciation mais au
niveau de l'État récemment qu'on est on
est très respectueux nous sommes un
peuple très respectueux pour celui qui
représente en détail ici mais
en termes concrètement sur le terrain
ici ben non quand on veut parler de
l'éducation le ministre de l'Éducation
vient à Paris tous les mois d'août de
septembre pour négocier toutes les
nouvelles formations pour l'année
d'après qu'on veut parler de
du social ou quoi c'est la ministre en
charge du social de la solidarité qui se
déplace à Paris alors d'ici je vous
apprends rien quand on parle des
militaires le commissaire et le numéro 1
de l'État ici elle n'a rien à dire
parce que c'est un monde on le sait
c'est qu'on m'a parlé aussi c'est chacun
sa bulle sur le judiciaire le procureur
général tout ça et ben c'est eux aussi
de leur bulle parce que comme on dit à
moi la petite bronzer de Polynésie
déconcentration de l'État pour moi c'est
le numéro 1 de l'État le représentant
selon commissaire pour les communes
veulent négocier avec l'État ils font le
petit champ même dans le bureau mais les
mains sont obligées de prendre leur
parcours de pèlerin et venir à Paris je
vous apprends rien ouais pour te dire un
peu concrètement le mot déconcentrations
du service de l'État c'est c'est une
réalité mais nous sommes respectueux
nous respectons et heureusement qu'on
est bon bon ami parce que nous sommes
respectueux de l'autorité de l'État qui
est chez nous mais jusqu'à quand j'en
sais rien voilà c'est ça la réalité
merci président monsieur le Président de
la Polynésie monsieur le Président de
l'Assemblée mes chers collègues chers
Lana cher d'Eva je vais en débuter par
le volet un peu plus institut
constitutionnel selon vous quel serait
votre avis sur la fusion des articles 73
et 74 de la Constitution ouvrant la voie
des statuts sur mesure et la fin de la
dichotomie historique d'hommes comme
donc je pense que
et nous n'avons aussi déjà
[Musique]
je crois qu'il faut laisser à la
Polynésie son article et ne pas et ne
pas fusionner
l'ensemble de ces articles si on change
effectivement
d'être fait à cette dichotomie on peut
les hommes je sais pas là il faut il
faut il faut qu'on y réfléchisse mais
nous sommes nous en tous les cas
complètement opposé à la à la fusion de
ces articles
quel sens de niveau notion de
différenciation de responsabilisation et
d'autonomie
française et j'ai eu même l'occasion de
le dire à l'Assemblée nationale lorsque
j'étais sur les bancs de l'Assemblée que
la notion d'autonomie va de paix avec la
motion de différenciation et la notion
de responsabilisation il faut
effectivement
moi je pense que
lors des débats d'ailleurs je pense
qu'au Sénat c'est c'est le même c'est le
même état d'esprit lorsque l'on démarre
sur sur la Polynésie lorsqu'on débattre
la Nouvelle-Calédonie bien souvent
effectivement nous demandons
l'adaptation des lois
en tenant compte des spécificités des
uns et des autres et je pense que
c'est clair que les spécificités de la
Polynésie française ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes aussi on est dans le même
bassin que les spécificités
calédoniennes ou les spécificités ou
alésiennes et et
[Musique]
il faut il faut effectivement attacher
de l'importance parce que je vois bien
je vois bien cette fonction de statut
d'autonomie applicable avec un cadre
commun si vous voulez sur la répartition
des compétences et encore que
ça dépend des spécificités économiques
locales
mais
je vois bien effectivement un cadre qui
rassemblerait l'ensemble des compétences
qui seraient délégués par l'État aux
différentes collectivités différentes
mais il faudra pas passer outre le fait
que la vie les populations de nouvelles
Calédonie le réagissent pas de la même
façon que les populations de
de Polynésie parce que c'est pas le même
environnement parce que c'est pas la
même activité économique voyez-vous ici
nous vivons essentiellement du tourisme
et des ressources de la mer en
Nouvelle-Calédonie sont dans la mine et
l'hôtellerie Google le tourisme est
vraiment secondaire donc il y a à mon
avis on conçoit bien je vois bien aussi
votre souci de quelque part
de mieux coordonner tout ce qui est de
la gestion des de ces collectivités
d'outre-mer parce qu'on en a besoin il
faut il faut qu'il y ait quelque part un
tronc commun mais ce ne sera pas
statutaire je veux dire par là que
l'ensemble de statues qui sera qui
serait applicable dans la Calédonie ne
sera jamais la même que l'ensemble du
statut et qui serait appliquer avant la
police
donc ça revient effectivement à ce qu'on
fasse du sur mesure et qu'on adapte si
vous voulez les statuts aux spécificités
des uns et des autres
sur le citoyenneté polynésiennes a été
évoquée elle supposerait la modification
de la Constitution quel contenu
attachez-vous à cette notion et
êtes-vous favorable y a-t-il d'autres
dispositions de l'article 74 de la
Constitution que vous souhaiteriez
modifier
sur la notion de citoyenneté
effectivement
il y a eu ce débat c'est
on en parle pas souvent depuis si
longtemps le débat est monté en
puissance avec la préparation des
élections législatives
mais en fait ce débat est sous tendu par
d'autres débats deux autres débats que
sont la protection de l'emploi local et
la protection du foncier local
nous sommes très jaloux à de notre
foncier parce que contrairement à la
Calédonie nous avons peu de plein nous
avons très peu de plaines ici en
Polynésie nous n'avons pas des grandes
surfaces
subissent le traités
nous avons aussi ici en Polynésie un
attachement qui est assez particulier
qui est un attachement
océanien à la terre même si nous vivons
de la mer mais nous reconnaissons que
nous sommes issus de la terre et que la
terre est extrêmement liée à l'océan non
ceci fait que aujourd'hui
on voit effectivement grand une
spéculation sur la vente des terrains
ici en Polynésie française qui au fait
que effectivement
[Musique]
pour la plupart
c'est dû à des éléments des éléments
extérieurs qui viennent investir par
exemple je vous le je vous le donne mais
c'est vraiment que pour dernièrement
lorsqu'il y a eu cette crise en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
juste avant les élections du référendum
effectivement certains calédoniens se
sont dit nous on va aller se mettre
quelque part on va aller investir
ailleurs parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que
ça va devenir donc ils sont venus
française ils n'ont pas acheté ça n'a
pas été arabe Marie chez nous mais il y
a une spéculation avec certains de
certaines de ces personnes qui
effectivement dans l'emplacement dans la
panique ont voulu investir ici et ça
fait flamber les prix mais ce n'est pas
que
vous imaginez bien la Polynésie est
devenue aussi le Havre que l'on
recherche lorsqu'on arrive à la fin de
sa vie en la retraite on a envie
d'investir en Polynésie parce que la vie
est plus belle ici et plus douce comme
certains autres comme dans certains
autres
présidents collectivité voilà donc c'est
ce souci là nous avons et d'autres avant
moi des gouvernements indépendantistes
puisque je suis oscarte et Malo avait
fait une première tentative de monter
une loi de pays qui permet de réserver
les emplois locaux à développer et je
vois qu'ils avaient introduit la motion
de la langue tahitienne de la langue
polynésienne si vous ne savez pas parler
le Polynésien vous n'avez pas droit
c'est ça je regarde mes techniciens
autour de moi mais pas droit à un emploi
et bien sûr que dans ces états n'a pas
apprécié cela et on comprend très bien
on comprend bien donc ça fait un peu
découragé tout le monde nous avons
repris le flambeau derrière en parlant
d'un certain nombre d'années de
résidents en Polynésie française avant
de pouvoir avoir un emploi localement au
moment où nous parlons nous venons
d'adopter la liste des emplois réservés
aux Polynésiens mais voilà mais il y a
un empressement parce que aujourd'hui le
taux de chômage en Polynésie française
est élevé il faut le reconnaître
beaucoup de temps emplois chez nous et
sans emploi
aussi avoir le niveau de soleil donc
c'est ça qui a soutenu la notion de
citoyenneté mais ça n'a pas moi je vous
dis c'est un sentiment tout à fait
personnel ce thème citoyenneté ne me
plaît pas tellement parce que
de vouloir écarter certains et garder
que d'autres
c'est ça qui me fait peur sur cette sur
ce mot un citoyenneté et je ne veux pas
je ne veux pas la Polynésie est
accueillante
voilà
et contre notre conception
océanienne des choses mais le souci il
existe le souci il existe donc il faut
vraisemblablement que l'on fasse se
fasse accompagner pas des spécialistes
du Sénat au de l'Assemblée nationale
consomment de pression effectivement sur
le plan statutaire tailler quelque chose
qui soit à la mesure de spécifique je
vous remercie et je vous comprends je
partage puisque saint-martiner ce même
problème de spéculation et cette
attachement à la terre
l'article 74 de la Constitution permet
l'adoption par les collectivités de
l'autonomie des mesures justifiées par
les nécessités locales en matière
d'accès à l'emploi de droit
d'établissement pour l'exercice d'une
activité professionnelle ou de
protection du patrimoine foncier on
avait vous fait usage souhaitez-vous
aller plus loin notamment dans d'autres
domaines
alors là dessus
la protection par exemple de l'accès
offensier oui le statut effectivement
prévoit des mesures mais nous estimons
aujourd'hui que le régime est et
nous ramène et qu'il faudrait
effectivement que l'on puisse rendre ces
mesures beaucoup plus souples et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous disais
tantôt je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait
qu'on est des séances de travail
ensemble là-dessus ou que nous puissions
effectivement trouver des solutions
beaucoup plus adaptées et plus facile à
mettre en oeuvre il en est de même pour
l'emploi local
là aussi il faut
local il y a il y a différents
paramètres qui doivent intervenir et qui
peuvent intervenir aussi et je pense en
particulier au droit du travail ici en
Polynésie française qu'il faudra
effectivement travailler un peu plus et
d'un peu plus près pour que ces mesures
de protection de l'emploi sont en bonne
année avec notre code
à ce statut de com des soins d'évolution
s'expriment-ils dans le débat public
qu'on est-il des socioprofessionnels une
possible révision constitutionnelle
suscite-t-elle des inquiétudes ou des
espoirs
aujourd'hui
bon les résultats des derniers
législatives bon c'est apparemment que
nous négligions pas aujourd'hui mais il
y a ceux qui vont défendre leur cause à
l'ONU et puis il y a ceux et aller voir
républicains parce que nous sommes quand
même rigides dans la Constitution
et puis on te demandait
aujourd'hui il mangeait parti de
Polynésiens restent convaincus à
l'autonomie à savoir le rattachement à
la France voilà on lui des débats
idéologiques que les autres parties
forment mais c'est que de l'idéologie
mais en terme de statutaire bien sûr que
nous avons totalement et il faut être
majorité à rester entièrement rattaché à
la République
dans les débats qui a eu en tout cas
dans la campagne qui a eu il y a eu des
métaphores un peu des mots citoyenneté
on pourra vocale mais en dessous voilà
si ça la réalité aujourd'hui
réalité de la politique aujourd'hui
alors compléter pour compléter ce que je
fais du bien de dire
la Nath étonnée
la notion de collectivité outre-mer de
quand de pays outre-mer
ne parle pas à la population
c'est pas des notions qui qui les
interviennent par contre la notion
d'autonomie
oui c'est une notion qui est importante
et comme disait l'anal la population
aujourd'hui avait à la pratique de
l'autonomie et qui permet effectivement
et ils le savent bien parce que bon
lorsque l'assemblée de Polynésie
travaille on sait qu'elle travaille
ça permet cette autonomie permet de
prendre des mesures plus adaptées à la
population plus adaptée à son mode de
vie et plus adapté à ça assez
préoccupations et la question de
l'évolution statutaire effectivement est
omniprésente dans le débat politique
mais
attaché à une opposition entre
autonomiste c'est-à-dire
républicain et d'autre part
indépendantistes c'est l'autonomie ou
l'indépendance et cette autonomie nous
en parlons ici chez nous parce que nous
savons que on est audible l'indépendance
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
parce qu'on essaie de réfléchir un petit
peu ce que devient ce pays si il est
indépendant et il faut dire que
l'auditoire se réduit de plus en plus
c'est la raison pour laquelle parce
qu'après les indépendantistes
aujourd'hui se tournent vers l'ONU
l'Organisation des Nations Unies à la
Commission des 24 pour interpellée et
appeler et puis bon et puis tout dire
tout ce qu'ils ont contre la France pour
démontrer que la France est une
puissance
colonisatrice ce qui est naturellement
complètement faux mais en fait dans tout
cela il s'agit de quoi je crois que le
vrai souci a des Polynésiens aujourd'hui
c'est de trouver de trouver au travers
et par ses élus tous les moyens pour que
la vie soit vide digne dans ce pays et
c'est vraiment c'est la préoccupation
les institutions que ça soit payé et
Associés indépendance
tout ça à mon avis ne les préoccupe pas
aujourd'hui et comme disait
le respect de l'État ici en Polynésie
française et quelque chose de réel nous
respectons l'État mais de plus en plus
aussi des Polynésiens demandent que
l'État nous respecte
l'état effectivement en Polynésie
française euh cela dépend bien sûr de
des personnes des personnalités qui sont
qui occupent ces postes
l'état de temps en temps un peu tendance
à mâcher sur les plates bandes du pays
et ça c'est très très mal perçu en
premier
je vous remercie je vais j'ai juste
revenir sur la fusion des articles 73 et
64 que vous avez dit être opposé j'ai
reformulé et précisé ma question en fait
seriez-vous d'accord avec une réécriture
de ces deux articles qui effacent la
distribution d'hommes comme sans enlever
aucune garantie comme actuelle cette
réécriture configurée la boîte à outils
mise à disposition de chaque
collectivité enfin de chaque
collectivité d'outre-mer sans les
enfermer dans une catégorie qu'en
pensez-vous
parce que le plus bel exemple de ce que
tu es en train de me dire ici je sais
pas moi un genre de article à jeudi
n'importe quoi 76 pour tout les
collectivités outre-mer aussi bien
département après on écrit un tronc au
moins et puis je sais à la cave après
pour Jacques non non mais je dis ça le
plus bel exemple que les a est fait le
faut général des collectivités
territoriales c'est pour ça que je
m'amuse à chaque fois vous m'entendez
venu crier au CMA et au truc là que vous
avez écrit à 20 000 km
nous passons notre temps à venir à
chaque fois modifier pour adapter à nos
collectivités c'est important et je
n'arrête pas de dire à mon président
mais attention
fais attention quels seront les
garde-fous
quelque chose si on écrit quelque chose
pour tout le monde et puis on respectant
les spécificités de ça c'est un peu ça
la crainte que nous
si je peux rajouter quelque chose
sur la fusion des articles sont très 74
et 73 74 effectivement
nous sommes totalement en phase avec le
président qui est pas question qu'on
soit noyé dans un article commun
la cause de la Polynésie de t'apparaît
dans un article spécifique
ne serait-ce que la reconnaissance du
fait nucléaire
lorsqu'on a modifié la organique et
pourtant c'est écrit dans la l'organisme
a été voté le Conseil d'État a considéré
cette intrigue n'a rien de normatif donc
ça n'engageait personne ni l'État
il est parti concerné par les essieux
nucléaires c'est bien l'église un
engagement moral c'est tout dans
l'organique donc j'ai posé la question
quel est le support dans lequel on peut
inscrire dans le marbre
cet engagement de l'État voilà je pense
que seulement dans lequel c'est la
Constitution et bien d'autres et c'est
pour ça que il nous faut un artiste
spécifique parce que nulle part ailleurs
qu'en effet des essais nucléaires comme
Polynésie je pense parfois solder d'une
manière assez claire et ce qu'on doit
politique du nucléaire savez-vous que
les partis politiques se sont élevés
contre les essais nucléaires depuis que
Chirac a décidé de réaliser les cinq
derniers essais
avant cette période personne ne s'est
élevé contre les anciens nucléaires donc
on a fait 188 essais il y a aucun parti
politique c'est
seulement conseiller la qui a décidé de
faire simple et d'arrêter définitivement
c'est tout le monde
à ce moment-là voilà donc il faut pas
non plus qu'on qu'on perd une 38 ans
d'autonomie parce que l'autonomie a
démarré en 1984 tous ces faibles
autonomie revendiquent effectivement
cette avancée institutionnelle de la
Polynésie française que les Polynésiens
les élu polynésiens assument eux-mêmes
il est compétences transferts au pays
dans le domaine économique dans le
sommet de domaine social dans le domaine
de la fiscalité et dans le domaine
culturel toutes les décisions sont
prises par le pays et ça c'est très
clair dans l'esprit des Polynésiens si
on nous remet dans un pot commun des
collectivités en ligne de faire cette
ident moi je pense c'est très important
et j'étais témoin aussi de
la presque disparition de cette fameuse
dotation que Chirac a mis en place une
fois qu'il a décidé d'arrêter les essais
il a dit ok j'avais des essais mais tout
ce que le centre d'expérimentation payée
à la Polynésie française
en matière de fiscalité le droit
d'entrée des droits d'enregistrement
était reversé chaque année à la
Polynésie mais ça remplace pas
l'activité je fais tu n'as aucun effet
sur le PIB au contraire le PIB a chuté
on Polynésie française parce que bon on
a réussi à arrêter les nucléaires et
depuis cette époque on est passé bien en
dessous du PIB de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
donc
l'engagement de l'État la reconnaissance
c'est au fait le construire
l'économie et la Polynésie française
pour retrouver ce niveau PIB qu'on avait
pendant les essais nucléaires je crois
que c'est ça le vrai le vrai contrat
d'avenir entre la politique et l'État
il faut que ça soit dans la Constitution
je voulais préciser dernier point cher
ami j'ai pensé très fort cette semaine
le dernier débat il y a deux jours à
savoir la demande à constitutionnaliser
le droit à l'IVG je me suis exprimé dans
mon groupe si vous voulez constituer
quelque chose qu'on a déjà c'est la
position de la main si vous voulez un
truc en 2019 je vais demander à faire
inscrire à reconnaissance nucléaire dans
la Constitution fait son embrancher
sur lequel peut-être on voulait
s'entendre enfin inscrire dans les
connaissances nucléaire
je vais terminer avec donc l'amendement
qui était directement inspiré des
travaux de Michel Magra qui avait été
présenté lors de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle en
octobre 2020 au Sénat il refondait
justement les dispositions outre-mer que
pensez-vous de cette proposition de
rédaction
c'est la fusion
on a beaucoup parlé effectivement
[Musique]
on a on n'a pas on n'a pas effectivement
je lui disais qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
motivations
on n'a pas on n'a pas le même
comment on dit l'environnement on n'a
pas
même sur le plan sur le plan politique
vous savez
l'autonomie acquise par par la Polynésie
française
s'inscrit dans une longue histoire
on sait pas levé un jour en se disant
pourquoi pas l'autonomie au lieu de
territoire d'outre-mer
ça a commencé par un homme qui était qui
a fait l'histoire de la poésie qui a été
emprisonnée monsieur power
qui effectivement prenait prenez le fait
que la Polynésie était peut-être arrivé
à un moment
c'est presque c'est elle ou ses enfants
pourraient se prendre en charge ou ses
enfants pouvaient prendre en charge
l'infini et c'est ça qui a été construit
jusqu'en 1977 avec le premier le premier
statut et puis l'évolution avec
82 84
c'est vraiment au départ une volonté de
se prolongeur d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
avec toutes les difficultés que nous
connaissons en Polynésie française moi
je le dis ouvertement nous avons
souhaité l'autonomie prenons-nous en
charge on n'a pas il faut pas continuer
sauf naturellement dans des situations
exceptionnelles continuer à s'appuyer
sur la mère patrie parce que
effectivement la France a toujours été
là dans les moments difficiles voilà
donc c'est ça c'est un état d'esprit à
mon avis qui effectivement un peu
différent de celui
de mon ami et Maghreb mais oui oui je
lui ai dit que il faut pas il faut pas
il faut pas
je vous remercie je vais passer la
parole au président pour conclure oui
voilà merci je voulais simplement
conclure cette séquence et vous
remercier de la caractère direct de nos
échanges qui nous permettent qui nous
permettent de pouvoir avoir les esprits
encore plus clairs mais il était déjà
assez puisqu'en 2020 vous aviez déjà été
président assez clair quand Michel vous
avez auditionné dans le cadre de cette
délégation donc nous on va continuer nos
auditions mais c'est vrai que je
voudrais quand même juste préciser une
chose
dans notre esprit et je pense que le
président Macron d'ailleurs l'a rappelé
il n'est pas question s'il était
envisagé une nouvelle rédaction
d'enlever quoi que ce soit à aucune des
collectivités
et c'est certainement c'est certainement
pas la volonté du scénar ni la vocation
du Sénat je pense que vous l'avez bien
compris bien au contraire en réalité ce
qu'on pense c'est que certaines
collectivités ultramarines aimeraient se
rapprocher de statut plus autonome et et
on réfléchit je vous le dis très
librement parce que je pense que la
condition commence à se dégager la
dernière question de de Micheline aller
dans ce sens là c'est que
en fait ce qu'on aimerait
vraisemblablement c'est ouvrir le champ
des possibles parce que en fait il y a
deux niveaux il y a le niveau
constitutionnel qui fixe les grands
principes et il y a le niveau des lois
organiques qui partent territoire
décline les grands principes qui ont été
arrêtés et ce sont bien deux niveaux
différents qu'il faut bien avoir à
l'esprit les gens confondent parfois les
deux et pour moi ce sont deux choses
différentes si par exemple pour sa
pyramide clan et c'est le sénateur
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et pas le
présent la collectivité qui le dit ni
l'ancien président si on me dit qu'on
fusionne les deux articles et qu'on me
garantit que ma loi organique elle reste
en l'état où je peux la faire évoluer
sur certains points qui me paraissent de
voir être corrigés ça ne pose pas de
difficultés particulières mais par
contre effectivement je demanderai ce
que Lana évoqué c'est des garde-fous
pour faire en sorte que le bloc
constitutionnel soit complètement
sécurisé et notre volonté de toute façon
si on chemine vers ce sujet puisque un
moment donné Micheline Jacques et moi
auront rapporté au président Larcher
dans le groupe décentralisation des
propositions possibles sur ce sujet
c'est vraiment de sécuriser tout ce qui
peut tout ce qui doit l'être aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'il est pas question pour
le Sénat d'initier un mouvement qui
remettrait ou qui fragiliserait des
collectivités dans l'exercice actuel de
leurs compétences donc voilà les choses
sont je voulais l'apporter comme
précision parce que voilà je voulais que
vous compreniez que le Sénat est
évidemment du côté des collectivités et
que bien au contraire si le statut
d'autonomie est complètement
satisfaisant avec des adaptations qui
relèvent sans doute d'ailleurs de la loi
organique en ce qui vous concerne
c'est c'est il y a pas de débat vous
voyez c'est vraiment on n'est pas sur
une position dogmatique et au contraire
mais on sait par contre qu'il y a
d'autres collègues ultramarins qui on
virait vraisemblablement des évolutions
que vous avez connues et que nos
collectivités d'outre-mer les comme de
l'article 74 ont aussi connu et c'est
plus en fait dans ce sens là que le
mouvement est s'opérer aujourd'hui et
c'est ce qui nous habite pour pour ces
auditions mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
veut s'assurer quand même que dans tous
les territoires qui ont été auditionnés
par Michel et la délégation en 2020 le
constat est toujours le même les
souhaits sont toujours les mêmes où ont
pu évoluer et s'ils ont évolué tant
mieux s'ils ont évolué dans la loi
organique bah c'est peut-être une loi
granit qu'il faut toiletter à un moment
donné et commencer qu'en France
généralement on a une révision
constitutionnelle tous les 15 ou 20 ans
on se dit que peut-être le président
Macron va profiter de cette fenêtre de
dire pour offrir à l'Outre-mer aussi une
possibilité de faire évoluer les choses
pour ceux qui le souhaiteraient voilà
c'est vraiment une opportunité et un
champ des possibles et en rien une
position dogmatique voilà je voulais
simplement conclure avec ces mots pour
vous dire que nous sommes évidemment à
vos côtés et aux côtés de nos collègues
de Polynésie Teva a dû quitter
l'audition puisque ici à la Cour de
Justice de la République donc il est ils
ont une affaire en cours donc il a dû
nous quitter donc merci en tout cas
messieurs madame de cette audition et à
très vite j'en suis sûr pour continuer à
échanger sur cette thématique qui est au
mois de novembre si j'ai bien compris
président
voilà merci beaucoup merci je voudrais
merci vous aussi l'ensemble de vos
collègues autour de vous Micheline merci
non j'ai bien compris j'ai bien compris
effectivement c'est précisions que vous
apportez vous savez je pendant que vous
parliez là je pensais à une chose moi je
crois que il faudra envisager à court
terme
pour nos amis notre mec que ce soit
effectivement
des outils ou de Saint-Barth il faudrait
pouvoir envisager de les faire venir
jusqu'en Polynésie française et vivre
quelque temps avec nous dans l'exercice
dans l'exercice de l'autonomie vous
savez moi je suis convaincu que si la
Polynésie française est la
Nouvelle-Calédonie ont été acceptées au
sein du Forum du Pacifique des îles du
Pacifique vous savez que le forum c'est
que les indépendante c'est des îles qui
sont coupées de leur tutelle c'est que
des indépendants et nous sommes les
seuls automobilistes pourquoi pourquoi
avons-nous été adoptés par ces gens-là
parce que effectivement on se voit
depuis que je suis ici et je crois que
mon pays faisait mais on les a fait
venir chez nous c'est ton chien c'est ça
moi c'est pas moi Guinée ils sont venus
chez nous ils ont vu comment nous étions
dans ce pays j'ai signé avec eux
l'accord des leaders polynésiens avant
la cop21 que nous avons apporté à
François Hollande à l'époque mais ils
ont vu que et oui effectivement on n'a
pas besoin de passer la ligne de
l'indépendance pour pouvoir bénéficier
effectivement de compétences que l'on
peut exercer pleinement avec un haut
commissaire qui est à droite bien sûr et
toujours là mais en fin de compte ils
ont compris que nous pouvions décider
nous-mêmes et ça et ça c'est important à
mon avis mais il faut venir ici il faut
venir en Polynésie la masse occupera de
vous de ses collègues mais
venez la voir comment ça se passe à
bientôt merci bonne fin de soirée au
revoir et je viendrai avec plaisir
merci pour les enfants merci nana